in 1983 the girl known as 11 opened the
gates to the upside down
while this led to the temporary
disappearance of will byers and the
death of barbara holland the most
dangerous and impactful thing that
opening the gate did was allow the mind
player to access the human world
the mind player takes on an abstract
form often described as a shadow or a
storm
even being referred to as the shadow
monster like many characters from
stranger things it most likely exists as
an allegory for the communist leadership
that existed in russia at the time
and we'll get into how its behavior
reflects that when the mind player
enters the right side up world of
hawkins it may be the biggest threat
that the town has ever encountered we
are talking about the destruction of our
world as we know it
to learn more about the mind flair and
its connection to the ideology of the
soviet union
stick around to the end of this video
welcome to horror history the mind
player did not initially or at least
directly affect the town of hawkins
indiana in 1983 when the gate to the
upside down was first opened however
roughly a year later will byers sees the
mind flair for the first time
indicating its arrival to hawkins like
the demogorgon the mind player's name
originates from the manual of the boy's
favorite game
dungeons and dragons this shadow monster
demonstrates many of the traits
explained in the dnd manual
especially a tendency towards mind
control and being linked to its victims
that all starts with will so to fully
understand why the creature chose him as
its first victim i'm gonna have to take
it all the way back to will's first
visit to the upside down
[Music]
it is likely that will byers becomes the
mind player's first target because will
was the first person to go into the
upside down and come out alive
this means that the mind player could
have already had some familiarity with
him i assumed that it already started
infecting will on the upside down in
november of 1983.
when he's found he has a tentacle
suctioned to his mouth that they have to
carefully remove the tentacle is not
attached to anything specific it's just
kind of part of the upside down we've
seen the mind flare or as i sometimes
like to call it
the mf take control of nearly every
organism found in these tunnels so it
stands to reason that it was already
making some sort of infection into well
over christmas that year will coughs up
a slug into his sink drain that later
becomes edema duct i did an episode of
horror history on the demo dogs as well
since the mind flayer is essentially the
leader of the demo dogs this means that
it was in fact the mind flayer that made
contact with will in 1983. on the night
of october 28 1984 will
is enjoying playing at the arcade with
his friends when he's suddenly given a
vision that he's
back in the upside down it's here that
will actually sees the mf for the first
time
partially obscured by a dark cloud
filled with flashes of orange lightning
even though the mind flayer hasn't
technically flayed or taken over will
yet its connection to him allows it to
communicate its intentions without words
what do you think the evil wanted to
kill
to kill you not me
everyone else however will is only a
small part of the mind player's plan to
infiltrate hawkins justin henderson
discovers a new form of demigorgon which
he coins as a demidog
the mindslayer's influence over these
creatures and will represents what's
known as a hive mind or collective
consciousness
as a result any information that will or
the demo dogs learn the mind player will
know as well
this is an analogy to what went on in
the ussr in my episode on alexi i talked
about how there was constant
surveillance in the soviet union and its
citizens were being monitored to make
sure they were upholding communist
ideals
in the same way the mind flayer taps
into the minds of those who it chooses
to take control of and keeps them under
constant surveillance which goes a long
way to helping it stay in power the
mindflayer makes the demidogs dig a
tunnel system under hawkins the citizens
are left completely unaware of the mind
flair's existence apart from a few
farmers who have land above the tunnel
route who notice their pumpkins rot and
die
creating a lot of hostility between them
the mind flayer continues to reveal
itself to will
each time more vivid and more aggressive
than the last will
an avid artist draws what he sees in his
visions including a spider-like system
of funnel clouds
then on halloween will opens up to his
best friend mike wheeler about what he's
seen
it was like this this huge
shadow in the sky
only it was alive
[Music]
and it was coming for me the next day
after school will is again
sent into a vision of the upside down is
the mind flayer chases after him this
time even more aggressively than before
resulting in
this happening
will later explains what happened to his
mom and describes the mind flayer as
more of a feeling i've felt it
everywhere
i still feel it the next day he stays
home from school and appears to be sick
but instead of running a fever his
temperature is extremely low
this is a major trait of the mind flair
who likes the cold and wants to keep its
human host as chilly as possible this is
probably another part of the allegory of
the mind flayer being representative of
the soviet union in russia and the
greater region that the ussr had control
over the climate in that part of the
world is absolutely freezing by my
sunny socal standards so it's very
telling that the creature feels most at
home when temperatures are low
will very bluntly explains this when his
mom tries to draw him a bath
no what he likes it cold
much like citizens under the ussr will's
individual personality is being stifled
or hidden away under the mind player's
own personality
think of will like a citizen serving
under his communist leader
as hopper and mike come over to the
buyer's house to help will does his best
to convey what the mf
is doing to him he describes sharing the
same thoughts and feelings referring to
them as his now memories
they feel like memories but they take
place in the present rather than the
past
it's like he's reaching and talking more
and more
and the more he spreads the more
connected to whom my field
the mind player would soon face its
first major threat when chief hopper
digs his way into one of the veins of
the underground tunnel system and
catches a big surprise
when hopper infiltrates the underground
tunnels one of the tentacled vines
growing there sprays him
causing him to collapse and become
vulnerable you know i've used that clip
before but i don't think it's ever been
more relevant
however the mindflayer doesn't seek to
flee hopper the way that it's flayed
will
instead as will promised it just wants
to kill him as will and the others work
to save him the mindflayer has another
set of issues to contend with
scientists at the hawkins lab conduct a
test with the soil that they collected
from the areas with rotting pumpkins
they light a burner under the infected
soil causing a mini storm similar to the
one that will first saw the mind flare
in but this time on a much smaller scale
this is another example of the mf
reacting negatively to the heat as mfs
often do
at the exact same time we see yet
another example when a group of soldiers
burn off the tunnels with a flamethrower
will's connection to the mind flayer
causes him to writhe around in pain as
well there's probably no image in all of
stranger things that it's more
disturbing
after will is rushed to the hawkins lab
he's sedated and the pain subsides the
mind player demonstrates that will no
longer has much agency when he barely
recognizes the people that he knows in
other words the mind flayer is almost
completely in control
it makes will tell a scientist that the
only way to stop it is to send all the
soldiers to one specific place in the
underground tunnels but really it's just
setting up a huge trap to get revenge on
the soldiers that brought it so much
pain with their flamethrowers
after this happens mike realizes that
will is essentially a spy for the mind
player the idea of a russian spy posing
as an american citizen gives us another
real world parallel
the kgb was a soviet security and
foreign intelligence agency in place
between the 1950s and the 1990s who
controversially operated as a secret
police unit in the soviet union they
also sent spies to integrate in other
countries like the united states to get
information on those who may oppose
their communist ideologies
so if the flayed will represents the kgb
then i guess mike represents the
american cia
because he figures out that if they
sedate will it'll keep the mind flare
from being able to spy on them
this is basically like unplugging the
webcam the mind player could no longer
see into their lives
so the gang is able to escape the lab
well most of them
when will comes too he finds himself in
another unfamiliar location
because he does not know where he is
neither does the mind player that is
until will hears the buyer's phone ring
and realizes he's close to home
before the mind player can send any
monsters their way he's once again
sedated and relocated
when will and effectively the mind
player inside of him wake up they're
being blasted with heat lamps for the
first time will's appearance changes and
his face and body are covered with blue
veins which kind of looks similar to
what the underground tunnels look like
as nancy jabs a hot fire poker into
will's side because yes
nancy is the type of girl to stab a 1
000 degree fire poker into her
boyfriend's 13 year old brother in a
moment of panic the mind player comes
shooting out of will faster than a
halloween retailer out of an empty
storefront on november 1st
right as this happens 11 and hopper are
in place at the hawkins lab and using
oliver's strength and being overpowered
and stuff 11
closes the gates cutting off the mind
players access to the right side up the
demigorgons aren't able to survive
without their host but will
now free of the mind player is cool to
see another day but if we know anything
about the actual personality of the mind
flayer it's that this mf
has an appetite for revenge first it was
the flamethrower mercenaries but now its
sites would be set on 11 for cutting off
its access to the right side up
and it has every intention of making her
pay when the gate is reopened in 1985.
in the arms race of the 1980s the
russians were competing with the
americans in many things which included
going to space and
developing weapons the part that wasn't
recorded in the history books was that
this arms race also included finding a
way into this newly discovered realm
that we know is the upside down
they too wanted to open the gates but
instead of using a middle school-aged
carry white wannabe or
project mk-ultra they went about it in
the most russian way possible with a
giant nuclear drill which was hidden
under the new star court mall
in late june the russians succeeded at
opening the gates inadvertently or
inadvertently letting the mind player in
once again this time with a new plan and
a desire to get back at 11. instead of
using demogorgons demawogs demofrogs
demahogs or demidogs for its demolition
of all things democratical
it demonstrates its adaptability
realizing that it would be more
effective to flay people and develop an
army of human bodies as opposed to
growing an army of its own
it uses the abandoned brimbourne
steelworks warehouse as its primary
location a decidedly more human
accessible safe house than the
underground tunnels which would make it
easier to lure in human
victim it begins making its comeback by
infecting an army of rats who congregate
at the steel works and
explode after eating the wrong
combination of hazardous materials
it's the whole thing the sludge from
their guts and tissues comes together
and takes on a physical form of organic
matter which serves as the new physical
body for the mind flair
remember every time we've seen the mind
flyer before this it's just made up of
these floating particles
so this is most likely the first time
that it has a physical form the mind
player is no longer picky about who its
first human victim needs to be
literally just the first person to drive
by will be just fine unfortunately for
billy hargrove his late night milf call
ends up being more of a facial
penetration event as he's dragged into
the steelworks by the malevolent
creature
billy ends up with the same connection
to the mindflayer that will had a year
prior
being able to think its thoughts and
feel its feelings it also communicates
directly with him by presenting a dark
version of himself that speaks to him
the mind flayer's impact on billy is
immediately noticeable when billy is out
in the daytime he's sweating profusely
and
almost looks sick his skin even starts
to burn when exposed to the sun too much
when karen wheeler tries to apologize
for standing billy up the night before
he sees a version of himself smashing
her into a wall
probably as a result of the mindflayer
being active instead of going through
with this
billy overrides the mindflayer and tells
karen to stay away from it
probably for the better as billy tries
to cool off in a cold shower one of his
kill lifeguards heather holloway checks
in on it she asks if he's okay but what
billy hears is something different
take me to him but this time billy is
unable to go against the mind player's
wishes
[Music]
heather next comes too as she's being
carried through the steel works by billy
who's under control of the mind flare he
lays her down on the floor in an almost
ceremonious way and whispers to her and
don't be afraid it'll be our shot
just stay married she doesn't as the
mind player is
flaying it notices 11 using her powers
to spy on billy and is able to vanish
from her sight now the mind flare
spreads to new victims from host to host
similar to a virus this means that its
spread is not dependent on billy alone
an older woman in town
doris driscoll notices that she has rats
in her basement and that they're acting
very strange being aggressive and eating
fertilizer she believes them to be
diseased but eventually just like the
rats at brimbourne steelworks her rats
explodes allowing the mindflare to
materialize and infect her
as mrs driscoll is driven towards the
hospital she reaches out for the
steelworks as the ambulance passes
by it indicating that she wants to join
the source of the mind flare we never
see if the rats are responsible for
infecting anyone else but we do see
flayed billy and flayed heather sitting
down to dinner with heather's parents
eventually knocking them out as well
taking them to brimbourne steelworks and
bestowing them the same fate
once again the flayed looks sweaty and
awful i mean rough day at the office
dude the mind flayer does its best to
keep its human host cool to combat the
summer heat
it certainly doesn't help when billy is
lured by 11 and her friends into a sauna
at the pool
they lock him in and crank up the heat
in an effort to expel the mind player as
billy rides around in pain the mind
player's hive mind is still active
making mrs driscoll have a similar but
somewhat more hilarious reaction over at
the hospital
so the mind player takes over billy
making him smash his way through the
door which kind of makes me think that
the mind player somehow makes him even
stronger
billy is a pretty strong dude who spends
his free time pumping iron but he
literally bends and destroys a metal
pipe
i mean that's pretty impressive but i
guess we've seen stranger things
[Music]
billy's escape causes eleven to have a
throw down against him and while she is
able to save her friends the battle
leaves her collapsed on the floor in
tears
but as the mind player returns to
brimbourne steel works flayed billy
expresses deflate heather that this
fight was just as hard on him
the girl was it her yeah
it was her she knows now she knows about
me
she could have killed me yes
but not us
not us billy and heather are more
concerned about the collective whole of
the mind flare's influence rather than
their own individual well-being
this sentiment is not that far off from
the ideas promoted by soviet union
propaganda red army posters advertised
slogans that perpetuated the idea that
everyone together is better than the
individual
the idea is also reflected in the manner
in which the hive mind operates
the mind player can perceive the
thoughts and feelings of any of the
organisms that is flayed but will
billy and the other victims aren't
necessarily given any information in
return
just like the kgb might encourage
russian citizens to report suspicions of
anti-communist behavior while still
keeping its main agenda a secret from
the public
in the case of the mind flayer it was
building something big in the shadows as
the fourth of july
approached in the meantime more people
start to see the creature's physical
form after
jonathan byers and nancy wheeler fight
off the flayed hawkins post newspaper
employees they break down into sludge
just like the rats from the steel works
and the material is added to the
monster's body
nancy tries to escape and lock herself
in an empty room at the hospital but the
mindflayer's ability to turn itself
into a gelatinous elementary school
cafeteria food form allows it to leak
through the cracks
but before she can be added to the ranks
of the flayed eleven shows up and
aerates that
mf into the wall it's actually one of
the best air utes i think we've seen
after then getting aerated out the
window i think the mind player realizes
that it's no match for 11 when she's at
full strength and retreats into a storm
drain
certainly not the first time i've
analyzed a creature that utilizes a
sewer system to terrorize a small town
presumably there are more unknown
victims that become flayed a news report
at the end states that 30 people died in
a fire at the star court mall which is
probably a government cover-up for what
really went on there i'm guessing these
30 people represent all the victims of
the mind flair they would include doris
billy heather heather's mom and dad and
bruce from the hawkins post
which means there are probably 24 other
victims throughout hawkins
that also makes it clear what the mind
flare means when it repeatedly talks
about
building something like when eleven
infiltrates billy's mind to try to find
the source of the corruption and
accidentally pulls the mind player or at
least the flayed
portion of billy's brain into her own
headspace
you let us in
and now you are going
to have to let us stay don't we see
all this time we've been building it
we've been building it for you
if this is the case it shows that the
mind flare is kind of insane and this
whole thing was basically a revenge plot
before this i kind of assumed that this
was like a world domination sort of
thing but no the mind player is still
pissed about eleven closing the gates i
guess the lesson to be learned here is
don't go after someone else's dogs
that's not cool i have a feeling that
really pissed him off as eleven escapes
the grasp of the mind flayer within the
world of her own mind it had already
summoned everyone that had been flayed
sending them to the brimble and steel
works where they're broken down into the
dark sludge material and absorbed into
the stature of the mind player which
explains how it was able to grow from a
roughly seven foot tall monster at the
hospital
to basically a 16 foot big boy by
independence day and as with any good
independence day celebration there were
about to be some
fireworks who here wants to see
some fireworks
[Music]
while most of hawkins was distracted and
enamored by the colorful fireworks
display at the 4th of july carnival the
mind player was busy making more moves
in the shadows
having used eleven's own tactic against
her by stepping into her mind it now
knew her location and was hungry for a
rematch using its new
more powerful body another big showdown
occurs and although eleven is able to
once again get the upper hand by
dismembering two of the creature's
orifices it nearly captures her after
dragging her by the angle and she's only
able to escape thanks to nancy who
shoots the mind flare
eleven wards off the creature by using
what appears to be the full force of her
powers to split its head in two even if
only temporarily
however the bite on her leg leaves her
in tremendous pain the kids escape to
the mall where 11 passes out and it's
revealed that a slug
just like the one that will coughed up
on christmas in 1983 is moving around
inside her leg she's eventually able to
excruciatingly remove it but it seems
that it may have accomplished its
mission anyways because after this
eleven loses her powers at this point we
don't know with a hundred percent
certainty how this demawog left behind
in her leg might have contributed to the
hampering of her telekinesis but let's
look at what we do know eleven's powers
have never been
unlimited the more telekinetic heavy
lifting she does the bigger the
nosebleed she gets as a result
so we can conclude that her powers are
somehow related to her circulatory
system
when will was infected he became very
sick and required many hospital and lab
visits to recover
seeing as how the slug was moving around
inside of l i'm guessing that it was
able to infect her bloodstream which may
be the reason she's no longer able to
call upon her telekinesis billy locates
the kids at the mall and alerts the mind
flair to their location
it shows up and crashes through the
glass ceiling above the food court then
using its long arm searches them all
probably looking for 11 or anyone else
it can fly despite not being able to
rely on 11's powers this time the kids
still managed to almost outsmart it by
using a litany of sounds including the
engine of jonathan's car to lure it away
from 11 and everyone else at the mall
but this ruses only goes so far as billy
witnesses max and mike trying to help
eleven out of the mall and summons the
mind player back to her location without
her telekinesis billy has a much easier
time defeating 11 and brings her back to
the food court
offering her to his master in an almost
ceremonious way as we've seen him do to
others at the steel works
he even gives the same warning don't be
afraid
it'll be over soon just
try and stay very still
but elle's friends still have one last
trick and it is an explosive one
as we know the mind player doesn't like
heat so the fireworks that mike and
lucas stole from a grocery store earlier
end up being an ideal weapon to fight
back with they engage in a huge battle
really dealing some major hits on the
mind player in order to protect 11. now
throughout the video i've explained many
of the different ways that this monster
represents the communist ideals of the
ussr
so the fact that our american heroes use
4th of july fireworks a literal image of
usa patriotism and democracy to fight
the creature is the perfect symbol for
the 80s political subtext that has been
running over and under the first three
seasons of stranger things but
ultimately these efforts are only enough
to slow the mind player down
the final blow so to speak ironically
comes from the monster's greatest
servant billy hargrove who gets a little
bit of control over his own body back
after 11 enters his mind and reminds him
of his childhood
billy takes a stand against the mind
player and sacrifices himself to protect
his sister and her friends long enough
for joyce buyers to get to the gates to
the upside down
like the russian scientist alexi who was
executed for aiding his american friends
earlier that day the mind player no
longer has any use for billy and he
becomes a victim of its metaphorical
capital punishment however he would be
its final victim as the closing of the
gate causes the creature to immediately
shut down and die
but while this was the end of the
elementary school cafeteria lunchmeat
version of the mf we would see the
original shadow monster form looking
over rural america again
that's right i'm talking about rocket
league
[Music]
in 2019 during a good old classic game
of league the farmstead was thrown into
a perpetual state of upside down and the
mind flayer appeared for the first time
in many years
it seems by now the mind player has
pretty much forgotten about 11 and just
looms over the farm side and takes in
some good old games of soccer
now i know some of you are going to try
to say that rocket league isn't part of
stranger things canon but really i
imagine rocket league takes place so
many years after 1985 that it would
really be difficult to say that mike
lucas will and dustin do not eventually
turn into these little egg characters i
mean look you can see chief hopper right
there
so i don't really see anything to
suggest that rocket league is not canon
here
not sure about dead by day like that if
you want to see the histories of more
stranger things characters click that
playlist on the left
and if you love horror remember to
subscribe to cz's world for new horrors
every week
ring the death bell for notifications
and i'll see you in the next one
assuming we both survive